ce soir alors restez avec nous parce que
dans un instant on va parler de
l'histoire de Bruno Guillon et de sa
famille séquestrée et ligoté cette nuit
à leur domicile l'animateur de France
Télévision une histoire folle et on vous
allez voir on aura avec nous David
Desclos qui nous dira comment ça se
prépare parce que c'est vrai que de plus
en plus les Chéries les personnes
connues se font ligoter voilà
saucissonner chez eux comme on dit David
descla nous dira comment ils font les
repérages comment ça se passe voilà
c'est c'est un truc de fou he qui lui
est arrivé il y aura Reda béadin qui
sera avec nous secrétaire départemental
Unité SGP police du valdearne qui
connaît toute l'histoire qui va nous
dire exactement ce qui s'est passé c'est
une histoire incroyable pour le moment
si je vous dis Véronique montguillaau et
Marie monguilla elles vont être avec
nous dans un instant Véronique c'est la
femme de Philippe montguilla le
chauffeur de bus tabassé laissé pour
mort en juillet 2020 à Bayon et Marie et
sa fille elle était venue nous voir c un
des témoignages les plus poignants qu'on
a eu dans TPMP le procès des agresseurs
de ce dernier a eu lieu la semaine
dernière ils ont été condamnés à 15 et
13 ans de réclusion
criminelle est-ce que vous trouvez que
c'est assez déjà vous allez nous le dire
ici j'aimerais avoir votre avis vous
aussi d'ailleurs chez vous dans quelques
instants les deux femmes nous donneront
leur avis sur ces condamnations
sachez-le elles sont outré dégoûté
regardez rappelez-vous malheureusement
c'était en juillet 2020 ça avait touché
la France entière et nous notamment et
Véronique et Marie ce soir et ben on va
se dire que pour elle
bah le cauchemar continue regardez le 5
juillet 2020 le chauffeur de bus
bayonnaet conduit de passagers sans
titre de transport il leur impose d'en
acheter un plus tard dans la journée ces
deux mêmes hommes sont à nouveau dans le
bus conduit par Stéphane montguillaau
cette fois-ci les deux individus ne
portent pas de masque sanitaire la
situation dégénère le chauffeur donne un
premier coup de tête selon les images de
vidéo caméra surveillance puis se fait
violemment frapp par ces individus
laissé en état de mort cérébrale le père
de famille suomb à ses blessures 5 jours
plus
tard je remercier Véronique montguilla
d'être avec nous la femme de Philippe
montguillaot tué à Bayonne et Marie F
Philippe mont Guillot tué à Bayonne vous
êtes en tout cas magnifique toutes les
deux je suis très heureux de vous voir
parce que c'était un de mes plus grands
moments dans TPMP je vous avais reçu à
la suite de ce drame mais Véronique on
le rappelle 5 juillet 2020 tout bascule
pour vous bien entendu vous avez perdu
votre
Marie et euh vous attendiez beaucoup de
ce procès puisque la semaine dernière
les deux individus à l'origine du
meurtre de votre mari ont été condamnés
à 13 ans et 5 ans de réclusion
criminelle je voudrais juste que Gilles
euh pour nos téléspectateurs fasse un
petit point sur 13 ans et 15 ans parce
que ils ont déjà passé 2 ans oui
détenenstion avec les remises de peine
euh on peut la moitié la moitié la
moitié donc ce qui veut dire que dans
peut-être 4 ans 4 5 ans 15 ans il fera
au total peut-être 9 ans de prison voilà
ans de prison an ils peuvent être
libérés et reprendre une vie normale oui
il y a des remises de peine automatiques
il y a aussi des remises de peine on va
pas dire pour bonne conduite mais qui
sont attribué donc exactement dans un
lap de temps assez court ils peuvent
reprendre une vie normale Véronique et
Marie est-ce que vous attendiez un un
tel verdict ah non absolument pas on
s'est accroché pendant 3 ans là on est
on espérait voilà j'ai toujours demandé
une justice exemplaire pendant pendant 3
ans depuis qu'il est parti jusqu'au
procès et en fait voilà j'ai ce qui
s'est passé la semaine dernière c'est on
est on est choqué on est qu'est-ce qui
avait été requis 15 ans pour les deux il
faut préciser quand même que les
réquisitions du procureur ont presque
été suivies parce qu'à partir du moment
où il n'est pas jugé pour meurtre mais
pour viol voilà violence volontaire
voilà je vais vous dire moi moi ici
excusez-moi tous les soirs on devient
fou dans euh on devient fou ici en
France excusez-moi donc parce que c'est
bien c'est c'est ça qu'il faut le dire
au téléspectateurs c'est 15 ans et 15
ans qui ont été demandés donc il a eu 15
ans et 13 ans c'est la vie d'un père de
famille d'un mari euh qui qui est parti
eux ils le retrouveront jamais et là on
me parle de quoi de violence volontaire
ay entraîné la mort sans intention de la
donner euh euh violence volontaire a
entraîner la mort sans intention de la
donner non moi je peux pas l'entendre
non plus c'est impossible quand ça
démarre à 14h30 à 2 et qu'on revient à
19h à 4 ouis comme par hasard il y a pas
qu'un tram qui circulit ce jour-là il y
a pas que Philippe monuillaot est-ce
qu'on va rappeler l'histoire euh tu veux
la rappeler alors d'abord il y a un
premier incident pour qui se qui se
passe dans le bus parce que ces deux
personnes ne veulent pas prendre de
tickets voilà et plusieurs heures après
par un tragique hasard ces deux
personnes reprennent le même bus avec le
même chauffeur votre votre époux et donc
à ce moment-là il y a une vive
altercation ils ont bu une bouteille de
whisky entre-temps donc ils sont ivres
euh dans un état déplorable et donc il y
a une deuxième altercation qui se passe
et qui va se finir tragiquement à
l'extérieur du bus voilà et à ce
moment-là il va y avoir des coups voilà
et ça va entraîner la mort de votre mari
et père voilà alors quelques jours après
vous êtes vous êtes dans quel état
aujourd'hui euh Véronique et Marie euh
bon malheureuse tout le monde le sait
sauf que ça c'est en privé que ça se
passe hein quand on est dehors
évidemment on nous connaî on nous voit
mais on garde beaucoup en nous hein mais
quand on est à la maison c'est une notre
histoire là on est vidé on est déçu par
le procès hein déçu vidé sont jeunes
pour avoir elles ont été aux assises
elles ont été hyper digne voilà 5 jours
mais je veux dire c'est nous on aandé
ouais trois filles ben on a les trois en
ouais Marie Mélanie mais mais comme il y
avait 15 ans de requis il y a eu 15 ans
et 13 ans
toute façon c'était déjà joué d'avance
en fait ENF il vous vous vous auriez
vous auriez aimé quel quelle peine moi
je demandais 30 ans c'est pas difficile
30 ans voilà en plus ce sont des
récidivistes hein je suis désolé donc
quand on entend 15 et 13 avec des avec
tout ce qui et puis tout ce qu'ils ont
fait en prison aussi enfin je veux dire
c'est c'est est-ce que vous ê est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec avec eu bah moi
envie
sair oui à partir du moment où en mai
2022 le meurtre aggravé parce que il
faut préciser que c'est aggravé parce
que en réunion en récidive et contre un
agent de service public trois facteurs
aggravants à partir du moment où je
n'avais pas compris d'ailleurs pourquoi
on ne parlait plus de meurtre aggravé
mais de violence à partir de ce
moment-là je savais en suivant le procès
en plus que la peine serait moindre par
rapport à ce que vous pensez excusez-moi
il y a tout à revoir et il paraît qu'
ils vous ont nargué pendant le procès
oui pendant le le procès on est pas on
était tout près du boxe les accusés il y
en a un des deux qui a fait que nous
fixer sauf que les mont guillaon ne
baissent pas les yeux non plus voilà
donc et puis il s'amuser il nous
regarder vas-y je regarde à droite à
gauche non en fait et nous ben on l'a
fixé aussi quoi ça a été ça pendant les
5 jours on l'a signalé hein bien
évidemment mais ça n'a pas changé donc
voilà on peut tout signaler maintenant
ça change jamais rien oui ça change
jamais rien de toute manière on est à on
est à la ramasse compé dans notre pays
donc je vais dire il y a rien qui va
changer quoi Marie euh forcément tu as
perdu ton papa ça a été déjà un premier
drame et
derrière ta maman toi et tes sœurs vous
êtes forcément déçu du verdict je
franchement je pourrais jamais être
avocat moi défendre des gars comme çaand
tabasse à mort quelqu'un c'est pour le
tuer quand le tabasse à mort c'est pas
c'est pas pour l'esquinter c'est pour le
tuer Mar qu quand vous apprenez que
votre père s'est fait prendre des coups
de pied dans la tête pendant 1 minute 41
s entraîné sa mort qui a entraîné sa
mort après on est revenu lui mettre un
dernier point comme dit Monsieur à côté
de moi on peut pas dire qu'on a' pas
voulu donner la mort mais mais mais
c'est ça mais je on a voulu donner un un
coup un coup pour le mettre KO ben un
coup un coup de pied par-ci un coup de
pied par là ouais je sais plus où j'ai
tapé j'ai tapé par là ouais la tête
c'était que la tête qui était visée non
mais il il qu quand on dit battu à mort
c'est c'est il y a des mots on s à
partir du moment aussi vous entendez euh
l'expertise hein psychologique là d'un
des deux qui dit que c'est moi qui a tué
mon époux parce que je demandéis à ce
qu'il soit débranché B ça c'est pas du
tout comme ça en fait quand j'ai pris je
le savais mais quand je l'ai réentendu
pendant les assises j'ai c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible quoi moi je
drait tout pour qu'on épous soit là tout
et donc on voit qui en a à faire on voit
que voilà c'est ça a été jou d'avance
comme vous dites bien évidemment on le
sait VO j'ai encore pas mal de questions
à vous poser Marie et Véronique parce
que cette histoire est incroyable on va
parler dans un instant de l'animateur
Bruno Guillon l'animateur de France 2 et
sa famille séquestré ligoté cette nuit à
leur domicile
on fait cette émission on se dit tous
les jours c'est c'est voilà et comme et
lui aussi on sait pas ce que vont
devenir les les agresseurs para qu'ils
sont filmés sur les réseaux et cetera
mon guillaot ce chauffeur de bus qui a
été roué de coup à mort qui a disparu le
5 juillet 2020 tout a basculé pour
Véronique pour Marie et pour ses deux
sœurs à Marie ce jour-là votre vie a
basculé et là le procès a eu lieu et si
vous nous regardez ce qui est fou c'est
que en fait euh il avait été demandé 15
ans 15 ans de prison pour les deux 15 et
15 15 et 15 il y a eu 15 et 13 qui ont
été donnés puisque il s'agit c'est plus
d'un hicide volontaire mais de violence
volontaire et entraîné la mort sur
l'intention de la donner j'ai une
question à poser parce que d'accord alle
les 15 ans et 13 ans il y a toujours des
remises de peine est-ce que il est
possible qu'il n'y ait pas de remise de
peine et qu'il fasse vraiment les 15 ans
et les 13 ans c'est impossible oui il y
a des remises de peinees automatiqu
d'accord donc c'est ça quelques mois
chaque année c'est automatique ensuite
après c'est le comportement
donc Véronique et Marie elles peuvent
revoir les agresseurs donc de leur père
et de leur mari dans dans 6 ans dans 7
ans tranquille toujours dans un bus quoi
tranquille c'est ça donc on est d'accord
ouais c'est exactement ça ouais c'est ça
qui vous a c'est ça qui vous a rendu fol
ah mais complètement enfin je veux dire
à partir du moment où vous enlevez la
vie à quelqu'un enfin dites 7 ans il va
dans 7 ans il ser ils seront libérés
enfin je veux dire il faut qu'il fasse
le maximum enfin c'est c'est
c'est moi ça me fait halluciner dans C
ans voilà il va être dehors nous on peut
le recroiser ou quoion j'espère qu'on va
pas le recroiser enfin on va pas les
recroiser hein bien sûr ah ils sont pas
de Bayonne hein sont de nime d'accord
oui mais même même c'est ils seront
dehors eux leur vie va continuer ouais
ouais mais ça suffit quoi ENF au bout
d'un moment enfin je veux dire moi je je
deviens folle avec ça aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce j'ai l'impression euh
Véronique que vous êtes dégoûté
complètement c'està-dire que voilà vous
dites vous croyez plus en rien ah non
complètement euh j'ai jusqu'au bout j'ai
dit
que je voulais faire confiance à la
justice jusqu'au bout je l'ai dit et en
fait euh ben non quoi c'est fini parce
que ça fait maintenant 3 ans 3 ans h que
votre mari est parti h euh comment on
fait pour pour se reconstruire parce que
je pense que dans dans tout ce lapse de
temps bien sûr il y
avait bien sûr la tristesse au quotidien
mais je pense que vous aviez aussi euh
ce procès qui vous tenait disiez voilà
je vais je vais voilà je vais vivre un
moment où mon mari va pas être vengé
parce qu'il reviendra il reviendra plus
mais j'ai ça qui me tient et aujourd'hui
non seulement le procès est fini donc ça
redescend mais en plus vous êtes
extrêmement déçu euh des peines voilà
qui ont été prononcé 13 ans et 15 ans
pour les les deux individus oui
complètement enfin je veux dire voilà
j'ai on a tenu avec les fill pendant 3
ans parce qu'on avait cet espoir de
justice on s'est dit moi j'ai j'ai
toujours dit il faut pas qu'il soit mort
pour rien et aujourd'hui il est mort
pour rien je veux dire là on en a la
confirmation qu'il est mort pour rien en
faitin et euh donc on a on a tenu parce
que voilà on voulait y croire tout
simplement on voulait y croire jusqu'au
bout ouais et quand on a eu le verdict
jeudi dernier enfin ça a été on la
Saline une deuxième fois à mon époux
ouais comment vous faites pour vous
reconstruire aujourd'hui on se
reconstruit pas pas pour l'instant euh
je je voilà je on survit ouais je
pensais que la justice nous aiderait à
réapprendre à vivre et en fait on on va
continuer notre survie on aura un déclic
à un moment donné nous quatre mais ça
sera nous toute seule les quatre
is
et donc on va on va essayer bien
évidemment moi je suis là pour les
enfants pour les filles faut les porter
faut les aider comment comment vous vous
vivez aujourd'hui vous vivez votre vie
de de mère
aujourd'hui pour vous vous vivez plus
votre vie de femme non fini ça c'est
fini pour vous c'est fini
ouais ouais
c'est ça s'est arrêté le 5 juillet 2020
ouis hm hm vous y pensez tous les jours
à C à ce jour ouais je pense vous l'avez
appris déjà par téléphone 1006 20h12 106
et je réponds pas toujours eu enfin je
réponds rarement un numéro que je
connais pas et puis là je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai répondu on vous a dit quoi
Verro est-ce que tes filles sont là
qu'est-ce ça peut te faire si mes filles
sont là où est-ce qu'elles sont et c'est
Yoo christopheambberé un ami à nous on
am mis à mon époux et en fait il voulait
savoir j'étais toute seule mais je
trouvais bizarre et puis un moment donné
je me suis dit mais ce qui est bizarre
c'est qu'il m'appelle à moi s'il a
besoin de parler à Philippe il travaille
dans la même entreprise que Philippe
pourquoi il appelle pas Philippe
directement ça ça m'a traversé l'esprit
et là et quand il me dit je viens
chercher Philippe à l'hôpital il se fait
agresser en fait j'ai je me revois comme
si c'était hier mais je je sorti de du
l' de ma maison pardon en hurlant parce
que non pas Philippe à M Malc il me fait
un bisou à ce soir ma chérie et à 20h12
on me dit
ça et les filles je appelé pour leur
dire de rentrer C à la plage ça quand
vous avez dû appeler vos filles ça a dû
être ah c'était c'est c'est dramatique
c'est dramatique parce que aujourd'hui 3
ans après on a l'impression que vous le
vivez comme si c'était hier oui ouais
parce que j' avec les filles on y
repense tout le temps on a que c'était
hier voilà pourtant ça fait 3 ans mais
le manque l'absence le le vide dans
cette maison le le garien tout tout ça
ça s'est installé et ça nous et on pense
tout le temps à lui on est j'ai un
mémorial à la maison ah oui mais ouais
ouais on y va chacune son tour pas
ensemble mais on y va on va lui parler
je vais lui souhaiter son l'anniversaire
de Mariage notre anniversaire de mariage
c'était le 26 août là j'étais le
souhaité à une photo à une une belle
photo une grande photo enfin tout tout
est comme ça les filles c'est pareil
enfin je veux dire donc on essaie on
Essie voilà on est on est déjà en un
tempérament de de battante on va dire
voilà on se laisse on s'est jamais
laissé aller on s'est toujours voilà la
photo c'est celle-là ouais à laquelle je
parle
et ça c le 26 août je crois et voilà
donc du coup on on s'accroche comme on
peut voilà qu'est-ce que ça aurait
changé si les deux agresseurs avaient
pris 30 ans qu'est-ce que ça aurait
changé pour vous parce que
votre pe elleaté la même oui tout à
faitpr parce que c'est important que
voilà je pense que vous avez pensé
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que ça a changé pour
vous pour votre fille j'aurais pu comme
je l'ai dit euh commencer mon deil ouais
là là je commence pas ah ouais non vous
êtes quoi dans vous êtes dans un
sentiment de quoi de haine de revanche
de vengeance de de dégoût dégoûté voilà
éige non vengeance non ça servir en fait
tout ça ça servira à quoi à rien du tout
de toute manière donc mais voilà le le
le le dégoût le dégoût de voir que
aujourd'hui euh c'est ce qu'on se dit
avec nos fill et puis et puis je ve vous
dire tous les gens qui étaient au procès
avec nous euh euh les gens qui sont sur
les réseaux avec nous tout le monde est
révolté de ce verdict tout le monde est
révolté il y a pas que nous quatre enfin
on est on est nombreux donc il y a un
dégoût parce que voilà on se dit mais
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on s'est dit
nous on peut tuer et on prend 15 ans
même pas pas 15 ans la remise de peine
on va prendre on va prendre 8 ans voilà
8 9 ans ouaà exactement ENF se
leementond à l'envers Marie tu as quel
âge Marie déjà 21 21 ans ton papa est
parti donc tu avais 18 ans 18 Comment
justement c'est quand même tu étais il
est parti à 18 ans c'est tu te construis
ta vie de ta vie de femme h comment tu
as fait pour te construire sans ton papa
est ce que euh tu pensais tous les jours
tu aussi est-ce que tu arrives à à vivre
ta vie de de jeune fille c'est très
compliqué h par qu'on te voit là je te
vois tu es tu essayes d'être souriant tu
es tu es tu es magnifique vraiment les
deux vous êtes vraiment on le voit vous
vous donnez le change comme on dit hein
c'est vrai toutes les deux mais c'est
vraiment des efforts pour vous de de
vivre oui complètement avec mes sœurs on
avait 18 21 et 24 ans quand ça s'est
passé aujourd'hui 21 24 et 27 chacune on
a pris un chemin de
vie
différent mais on voit pas plus loin que
demain en fait parce que c'est hyper
compliqué mais de perdre quelqu'un comme
ça si soudainement si
brutalement et de se construire derrière
pour bah notre nos vies de jeunes femme
en fait sur les projections personnel
professionnel immobilière même c'est
enin on VO pas plus loin que demain et
là le procès il a c'était vraiment
quelque chose qu'on attendait comme
maman a pu le dire
ouais là cette semaine on est beaucoup
sur la R descente c'estàdire que les
nerf étaient tellement à vif ça exement
c'est ça donc là redescente et déception
ouais c'est ça ouais donc on s'occupe en
fait les journées
mais sans sans but là pour l'instant
pour l'instant là pour l'instant sans
but et euh et en fait on va voir on va
voir ce qui se passe dans dans les
prochains jours les prochaines semaines
comment on va commencer à amorcer le
deuil ouais même si on on l'aurait un
peu mieux amorcé si si on avait su
qu'ils avaient pris la peine maximal
c'est sûr
ou Marie et Véronique merci d'avoir été
avec nous vraiment c'est toujours un
bonheur de vous voir vous et vous êtes
formidable vraiment les deux j'avais un
souvenir de vous vous m'aviez vraiment
marqué parce que c'était une histoire
vraiment qui m'a qui m'a beaucoup touché
et je vous dis j'ai moi j'ai en tout cas
j'ai la rage voilà j'ai la haine même si
vous vous ne l'avez pas et c'est vrai
que c'est vraiment inadmissible ce qui
s'est passé et je vais vous je relis ça
parce que je relis ça parce que ça m'en
fout je vrais terminer par ça pour vous
qui nous regardez à 20h50
violence volontaire ayant entraîné la
mort sans l'intention de la donner des
personnes qui ont passé une minute 40 à
mettre des coups de pied dans la tête et
pour une
altercation
nulle zéro et est mon et il est mort les
mot on va te démonter à l'extérieur on
va te finir je trouve que on marche sur
la tête dans ce pays merci en tout cas